ich begrüße Sie ganz herzlich hier aus
dem Deutschen Bundestag Auftakt der
Haushaltssitzung und die Haushälter
haben wirklich sehr lange gesessen 18
Stunden über 1.000 Anträge in der
Bereinigungssitzung behandelt und es
wurde dann auch noch mal sehr viel
geändert ich kann mich kaum erinnern
dass so viel Geld hin und her geschoben
wurde bei der Neuverschuldung hat man
noch mal drauf gesattelt 31 Milliarden
und 13 Milliarden gab es für neue
Investitionen zusätzlich Christian
Lindner der Bundesfinanzminister hat
hinterher gesagt dass Ergebnis lässt
sich sehen das ist zu verstehen denn er
hat natürlich die Schuldenbremse doch
einhalten können das erste Mal seit 2019
und das Ergebnis lässt sich sehen wir
wollen mal darüber diskutieren dieses
Ergebnis erstmal zu verstehen und dafür
habe ich mir zwei Fachleute eingeladen
Otto Fricke den Haushälter der FDP und
Gesine lötz die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzen und auch die
haushaltspolitische Sprecherin ihrer
Fraktion Herr Fricke zum Verständnis
fangen wir vorne mal an also wir haben
haben ja die Schuldenbremse die wird
eingehalten und
wir haben eine konjunkturelle Notlage
also wenn man die nicht hätte dann hätte
man 12,6 Milliarden aufnehmen dürfen
jetzt ist die konjunkturelle Notlage
dazu gekommen da haben Fachleute
ausgerechnet 15,3 Milliarden warum das
und dann gibt es noch
Finanztransaktionen die nicht in die
Schuldenbremse verrechnet werden wie zum
Beispiel
ihre alt ihre aktienrente das müssen wir
uns jetzt noch mal erklären also es gibt
Regeln aber die sind ganz intransparent
wie ich finde eigentlich sind sie nicht
intransparent sie sind nur komplex und
wir haben es auch mit einer komplexen
Wirtschaft zu tun was ist der
Hintergedanke die meisten Jungs jetzt
zuhören sagen ja wir haben doch
eigentlich eine schwarze Null also
erstmal die schwarze Null weg nein
schwarze Null ist etwas du darfst gar
keine Schulden machen das ist ökonomisch
nicht sinnvoll das wäre wie wenn jemand
ich setze das immer ins Privatleben sagt
ich spare bis ich 65 bin und dann
schaffe ich es vielleicht mehr meine
Wohnung oder meine Haus zu kaufen das
zweite ist viele denken die
Schuldenbremse ist statisch die sagt
einfach so hier ist die Gren Anschluss
die hat aber auch wieder bildlich
gesprochen ein Antiblockiersystem ist es
nass dann ist der Bremsweg länger das
bedeutet auch wir können etwas mehr
Verschuldung machen wenn die Wirtschaft
nicht gut läuft das ist der Grund warum
wir über die 12,5 Milliarden die der
normalver sind rüber hinausgehen können
wäre es trockenwürdig die Wirtschaft gut
laufen während wir bei 12,5 oder sogar
unter 12,5 wenn die Wirtschaft gut läuft
das heißt sie atmen und passt sich an
die Wirtschaftssituation an damit in
schlechteren Zeiten mehr ausgegeben
werden kann dann gibt es noch und da
wird es dann kompliziert die
Notsituation die wir in den letzten
Jahren haben wo wir sie aussetzen weil
es gar nicht anders geht das haben wir
jetzt in diesem Haushalt auch wieder
gesehen und das was uns das
Wirtschaftsministerium die
Sachverständigen gesagt haben wie sich
die Wirtschaft im nächsten Jahr
entwickelt erlaubt uns mehr Schulden zu
machen und der letzte Punkt ist
gleichzeitig sagt die Schuldenbremse
wenn du über einen Darlehen etwas
investierst dann darfst du das
zusätzlich im Bereich der Schuldenbremse
nutzen denn du bekommst an der Stelle
das Geld zurück und bei der aktienrente
haben wir eine Finanzierung die wenn die
aktienrente läuft dann auch wieder
zurückgezahlt wird neuen Bundeshaushalt
hallo Sie sind auch schon ewig in diesem
Haus Haushaltsausschuss gerade diese
aktienrente ist ja die Idee der FDP die
kommt jetzt so hinterher gekleckert wenn
ich mir das anhöre wundere ich mich dass
andere Finanzminister nicht ihre Träume
und Ziele immer durch so ein Konstrukt
schon in den vergangenen 40 50 Jahren
haben finanzieren lassen ja ich will mal
diesen Begriff das ist glaube ich ein
kleiner freundschaftsversprecher gewesen
Hintergedanken aufgreifen die
aktienrente ist in der Tat ganz kurz vor
der Sitzung noch mal in der sogenannten
bereinigungsvorlage durchgedrückt worden
ich hätte mich gefreut wenn wir anstatt
der aktienrente einen Prestigeprojekt
der FDP was sowieso scheitern wird wir
kennen das ja aus vergangenen
Finanzkrisen wenn man diese aktienrente
zum Beispiel endlich die
Kindergrundsicherung geschlossen hätte
aber das ist leider keine Priorität der
Bundesregierung erster Punkt zweiter
Punkt Otto Fricke hat nur sehr
ausführlich die ganzen Regeln erklärt
aber eigentlich haben wir doch nur eine
Schlussfolgerung ziehen die
Schuldenbremse ist ökonomischer Unsinn
das sagen wir schon lange sie gehört
wirklich auf den Müllhaufen der
Geschichte müsste aus dem Grundgesetz
wieder gestrichen worden da ist sie ja
durch Abstimmung von Abgeordneten
reingekommen und das sind lauter Tricks
Taschenspieler Tricks aufgebaut worden
um diese Schuldenbremse zu umgehen ich
sage mal als Stichwort Sondervermögen
100 Milliarden extra für die Bundeswehr
jenseits der Schuldenbremse dann noch
mal ein 200 Milliarden Sondervermögen
auch jenseits der Schuldenbremse das
Problem ist nur dass irgendwann ja die
Rechnung präsentiert wird und die Frage
wer die Rechnung bezahlen soll die ist
nicht beantwortet worden und die
Sachverständigen die Otto Fricke ja auch
schon gerade kurz angesprochen hatte die
Wirtschaftsweisen haben gesagt wir
brauchen jetzt eine Steuererhöhung und
zwar für die die wirklich viel Geld
haben und das ist unsere Forderung das
gut dargestellt also Holzschnitt hatte
ich noch mal die Frage warum hält man an
so einer Schuldenbremse fest wenn doch
der Steuerzahler der Bürger in
Deutschland irgendwann diese 100 und
diese 200 Milliarden und wie die
Sondervermögen alle heißen sowieso auch
zahlen muss mit Krediten und mit der
Abzahlung das ist doch eigentlich ein
Taschenspieler Trick wenn er auch
vielleicht
erlaubt ist aber verstehen zu Hause wenn
man zur eigenen zum eigenen Banker ginge
würde das so nicht funktionieren jetzt
und das ist gerade das um es in dem Bild
klar zu machen das erste ist aber was
wir festhalten müssen wir haben hier
eine linke Partei sie sagt die
Schuldenbremse ist schlecht wir müssen
mehr Verschuldung machen aber nicht so
rum würde doch die CDU stehen würde die
sagen die Schuldenbremse ist gebrochen
Tatsache ist es genau der Mittelweg und
jetzt komme ich zu der Frage weil ich
versuche das in Bildern zu erklären was
bedeutet das für den für den Bürger wenn
der Bürger sein Girokonto anguckt und
sagt ich kann nicht über die Null gehen
oder vielleicht den kleinen Kredit mit
dem man mir einräumen gleichzeitig aber
sagt ich investiere indem ich eine
Wohnung kaufe wo ich für einen Kredit
aufnehme und den aus meinem Girokonto
monatlich abbezahlen und genau das Bild
haben wir hier auch wir haben für zwei
Sonderfälle das eine weil wir geglaubt
haben wir haben eine Friedensdividende
weil das Objekt reicht zu Ende ist
müssen wir aber mehr tun für
Verteidigung sind wir aus unserem weit
überwiegender Mehrheit einig bis auf die
linke und die AFD glaube ich an der
Stelle und auf der anderen Seite für die
Frage Passhilfe energiehilfe stromhilfe
haben wir auch gesagt müssen was tun für
den Bürger bedeutet das ich finanziere
mein Haus habe hier eine Schuld die groß
ist wir haben das Sondervermögen als
Bund und finanziere es im monatlichen im
jährlichen aus meinen täglichen
Einnahmen und Ausgaben nicht habe und
dazu ist der Bund auch verpflichtet für
die Sondervermögen gibt es einen
Tilgungsplan der ab 2031 ansetzt und uns
dann hindert und da wird die
Schuldenbremse dann zeitverzögert das
ist auch so gedacht uns dann hindert in
den Jahren danach neue Ideen zu haben
wie wir Geld ausgeben können alles
kompliziert die entscheidende Frage ist
ja die Frage nach den Ausgaben und den
zur Verfügung stehenden Einnahmen der
Bundesfinanzminister hat also jetzt
darauf geachtet dass er genau diese
Einnahmen in diesen Grenzen gestaltet er
hat unter anderem zum Beispiel 40
Milliarden eingerechnet der Rücklagen
dieses Staates und da sagen viele aus
der Opposition von CDU CSU zum Beispiel
das ist unklug von ihm denn dieses Geld
kann man vielleicht im Jahre 24 25
besser verwenden die entscheidende Frage
ist glaube ich dass wir endlich
Steuersystem in Ordnung bringen müssen
und ich darf noch mal auf den Rat der
Wirtschaftsweisen oder
Sachverständigenrat beide Begriffe sind
ja allgemein bekannt Hinweisen sie haben
gesagt wir müssen für diese Situation
das war deren Rat die Steuern für die
wirklich sehr sehr reichen für einen
bestimmten Zeitraum erhöhen wir sagen
als Linke wir brauchen endlich eine
übergewinnsteuer denn in jeder Krise
gibt es Menschen die ärmer werden und
welche die reicher werden und in anderen
Ländern die uns wirtschaftlich
vergleichbar sind ist ja diese
übergewinnsteuer schon eingeführt worden
es ist ja nicht so dass nur die
Energiekonzerne übergewinne machen auch
die Rüstungskonzerne machen übergewinne
und wenn wir uns anschauen wie die
Lebensmittelpreise explodiert sind das
hat ja mit der Inflation gar nichts mehr
zu tun schauen wir nach Großbritannien
z.B die Mutterland das Kapitalismus da
gibt es eine übergewinnsteuer und was
sich jetzt die Ampel ausgedacht hat so
eine zufallsgewinnsteuer die steht ja
noch in dem Sternen die ist nicht
beschlossen worden und darum ist das
unsere ganz klare Forderung
übergewinnsteuer muss eingeführt werden
Stichwort die haben ja empfohlen dass
man zeitlich besser verdienende besser
zur mehr zur Kasse bittet oder aber
einen energiesoli für besser verdienende
ja man kann an der Stelle natürlich
immer das Spiel machen dass ich sage ich
nehme mehr ein dann wird das schon
funktionieren meine Erfahrung ist bei
aller nachvollziehbaren vermeintlichen
sozialen Gerechtigkeit wenn du es
überziehst bei der Frage wie du in der
Progression reingehst wenn wir jetzt
schon sehen wie der das obere Viertel
über 70% der Lohn und
einkommensteuereinnahmen finanziert da
musst du dir überlegen wie weit du da
gehen kannst und wenn das Beispiel
Großbritannien kommt und das als
Vergleich genommen würde ich glaube
nicht das Gesehene Lötsch gerne die Lohn
und einkommensteuerbeträge für gut
verdienende hätte wie sie Großbritannien
sind da sind sie nämlich niedriger man
muss das Gesamtsystem sehen und ich kann
dann an der Stelle nur aus Haushälter
sagen gibst du den Bund mehr Geld oder
dem Land oder der Kommune heißt das
nicht automatisch das entweder mehr
gespart wird sondern es wird einfach
mehr ausgegeben und da sage ich dann das
kann nicht der Sinn von vernünftige
Haushaltspolitik sein da bin ich dann
eben doch einer der sagt du musst mit
den Mitteln die du hast zu rangekommen
und muss da dann schauen was die Frage
angeht der der übergewinne werden wir
das jetzt ganz genau uns ansehen an
welcher Stelle übergewinne kommen denn
das muss man dann ja auch sagen das wird
auch heißen die Linke will für die
Betreiber von Windrädern die im Moment
sehr viele Gewinne machen wegen der
hohen Strompreise eine Sondersteuer
haben und nicht nur für Leute wie wie
jetzt sage ich mal Unternehmen wie RWE
und andere die die machen gleichzeitig
sage ich auch immer ich will ja gar
nicht übergewinne bescheuert ich möchte
eigentlich dass diese Unternehmen
investieren Arbeitsplätze sichern
Nachhaltigkeit ermöglichen das wird die
Aufgabe in den nächsten Jahren sein und
nicht die Frage ist der Staat noch mehr
Geld kriegt kommt die Standard Beispiel
ist ja mit den äh Windkraftwerken
natürlich sind wir dafür die
erneuerbaren Energien zu stärken und was
die Ampel jetzt macht ist ja genau die
Rolle rückwärts da wird zum Beispiel
Steinkohle aus Südafrika importiert ich
halt kann das mit Nachhaltigkeit
überhaupt nicht verbinden die Frage ist
natürlich gibt man wofür gibt man Geld
aus das ist doch die entscheidende Frage
und wenn wir uns anschauen wie viele
Menschen in unserem Land arm sind wieder
Zustand unserer Schulen ist mit der
Zustand von vielen Krankenhäusern ist
dass viele Krankenhäuser jetzt vor der
Situation stehen weil sie
reininflationsausgleich bekommen der
ausreichend ist schließen zu müssen dann
sage ich dafür brauchen wir mehr Geld
weniger Geld brauchen wir ganz klar für
die Rüstung das versandet sowieso ja
genau ich will mal auf die Ausgaben
jetzt schauen da hat der
Haushaltsausschuss noch eine Milliarde
bewilligt für Munition angeblich fehlt
der Bundeswehr Munition im Wert von 20
Milliarden Euro aber dennoch Herr Fricke
wichtig bei Ausgaben und Einnahmen ist
auch immer das was die Politiker
versprechen erzählt haben der
Bundeskanzler hat hier in diesem Hohen
Hause gesagt also zwei Prozent für die
Bundeswehr das wird nach Berechnung in
den nächsten vier Jahren überhaupt in
einem Jahr erreicht werden es sei denn
man nimmt aus dem Sonderhaushalt was
dazu aber so war das damals nicht gesagt
worden ist das nicht ein Bruch der
versprechen dieser ampelregierung also
entscheidend ist wir wollen auf Dauer in
dieser Legislatur auf diese zwei Prozent
weil wir eben nachholen müssen zweitens
die berühmten munitionssache ist eine
sogenannte Verpflichtungsermächtigung
wir ermöglichen den
Verteidigungsministerium für die
nächsten Jahre schon Verträge einzugehen
um eben in den nächsten Jahren aus dem
Sondervermögen mehr finanzielle
Möglichkeiten zu haben ja stimmt wir
haben jetzt im ersten Jahr nur acht
Milliarden statt 20 Milliarden
zusätzlich aus dem Sondervermögen aber
nach dem Motto einfach hauptsache ich
gebe das Geld aus egal was ich dafür an
Waffen bekomme wäre ziemlich blödsinnig
entscheidend wird jetzt sein in den
nächsten Jahren bleiben wir unter den 20
pro Jahr dann wäre es schlecht oder
gehen wir über die 20 und kompensieren
das so und da sage ich wenn ich neue
Flugzeuge neue Schiffe Panzer wenn ich
all das anschaffe dann will ich nicht
von heute auf morgen was haben das
gibt's nämlich nicht im Regal bei Aldi
oder sonst wo sondern es muss geschafft
werden aber das ist und da ist die
Verpflichtung dieser Koalition in dieser
Legislatur zu schaffen bei Bewaffnung
Militär kommen nicht weiter ihre
Position ist ja auch bekannt aber gucken
Sie mal auf den Haushalt gibt es da
irgendwas positives wo sie sagen das
hätten wir auch so gemacht und was fehlt
ihnen es gibt natürlich immer ein
Kleinigkeiten was positives aber was mir
vor allen Dingen am Herzen liegt ist die
Armut Bekämpfung und dass die Kinder
Grundsicherung auf das Jahr 2025
geschoben werden soll ist etwas was ich
überhaupt nicht akzeptieren kann und ich
werde die ganze Woche dafür Werbung
machen dass wir vielleicht zumindest bis
Freitag die Erkenntnis haben dass wir
die Kindergrundsicherung sehr sehr
schnell brauchen denn für unser Land
zerstört es auch die Zukunft wenn Kinder
in schlechten Situationen aufwachsen das
können wir nicht akzeptieren und ganz
kurz noch eine Frage an Herrn Fricke ihr
Parteifreund und Wolfgang Kubicki macht
sich heute Sorgen um den Fortbestand der
ampelregierung bzw um die Existenz der
FDP weil man immer nur nachgibt den
Sozialdemokraten und den Grünen so
ähnliches formuliert unter anderem
finanziert man also ein
Flüchtlingsschiff neuerdings was
überhaupt nicht Interesse der Europäer
sei so Kubicki wackelt hier die Ampel
nein ich sehe das nicht ich kann nur
sagen wir haben als Haushälter sehr gut
gehandelt und ich hätte sonst als
grundzeugen zu der Frage ob die FDP sich
wenig durchsetzen kann immer Gesine
lutscht sich wirklich durch also so
leise und das zweite bei dem Schiff ist
hier haben wir als Haushaltsausschuss im
Rahmen eines kompromissystem auswärtigen
Amt die Möglichkeit gegeben zwei
Millionen an eine Organisation zu geben
aber unter den Voraussetzungen dessen
was im Haushalt steht das Auswärtige Amt
wird das hier ordentlich Regeln und das
sage ich dann aber aber auch bei der
Frage ob Menschen im Mittelmeer sterben
oder nicht werden sie von mir als
Liberalen nicht hören dass mir das egal
ist Frau Lötsch als Kronzeuge in vielen
Dank dass sie da waren vielen Dank Herr
Frick